دعني اذهب معك باتجاه اخر في الحوار
السياسه نفسها التي انتقدت ماليزيا من
اجلها في بدايه القرن تكررت في السنوات
الاخيره البعض يعتقد بانه ماليزيا اصبحت
ملاذا
لجماعات غير مرغوب فيها بها في بعض الدول
جماعات متطرفه بشكل او باخر بالذات في
الدول العربيه اصبح مقرها ماليزيا هل هذا
صحيح ما مدى دقه هذا الكلام
لدينا اشخاص برو ان متطرفه او متشدده في
ماليزيا نعم ولكن اي اشخاص او اطراف
بانشطه عنيفه مثل التفجيرات والعمليات
الانتحاريه هذا لم يحدث في ماليزيا وفي
بلدنا لدينا خلافات ومع ذلك نحن لا يقاتل
بعضنا البعض بدون
صحيح ولكن هل استقبلت ماليزيا اي من
المتطرفين
المرفوضين من الدول العربيه هل كان في
تواصل ما بين ماليزيا وتركيا من اجل
استقبال هؤلاء مثلا
وخلينا نحكي بصراحه عن عن من هم تابعين
لتيار الاخوان في نهايه الامر
حسنا ماليزيا دوله منفتحه جدا وكل شخص
يمكنه القدوم الى هنا والبقاء لفتره طويله
ونحن دوله لها نظامها الخاص في سياسه
الدخول وغالبيه الجنسيات لا تحتاج تاشيره
دخول لدينا عدد كبير من الجنسيات التي
تعيش بيننا ولا يمكننا ان نحدد بني
الارهابي او مشروع ارهابي او متطرف من
بينه في بعض الاحيان ربما هناك ما يقيم في
ماليزيا ولكن كانت له اعمال عنيفه في دول
اخرى اما فيما يتعلق بتركيا فحتى الان
لدينا علاقه جيده معها سوفا
نعم ولكن هل هناك في ماليزيا اي من
المطلوبين سواء للدول العربيه كمصر مثلا
او لي اي دوله اخرى من من من هم متهمون
بالتطرف والارهاب هؤلاء ليسوا مواطنين
عاديين بالتاكيد اسمائهم لازم تكون معروفه
لدى الدوله الماليزيه
نعم ولكن لو يتم تمكيننا من ادله ومعلومات
تثبت انهم ارهابيون فساعتها يمكننا اتخاذ
اجراءات او يمكننا طردوهم من اراضينا ولا
يمكننا بالضروره ارسالهم الى دوالهم هكذا
من دون اي معلومات مثبته
بحجه ماذا يعني لماذا لا يتم تسليمهم
لدولهم اذا كانوا متهمين بالارهاب شمتان
كانتري في بعض الاحيان في بعض دول هؤلاء
هم لا يلقون محاكمات عادله وهذا يفرض
وعلينا مسؤوليه قانونيه واخلاقيه ولذلك
اذا رغبت اي دوله في الحصول عليهم فعليها
ان تبحث عنهم في دول اخرى غير ماليزيا